[Applause]
[Music]
you the only person i ever met
belonged in this guy
just remember you belong down here with
us too okay
[Music]
the commanding officer calls you one of
the best pilots he's ever seen
it must be hard being the naval aviator
absolutely
the whole world's looking different did
you ever think that you'd be in a
squadron with a colored aviator
lieutenant tom hudner jesse brown
it's good to meet you
we're taking a slight detour on the way
home say again
what are you gonna find out about your
wingman cruising at two thousand feet
lieutenant
put him in a little bit of trouble who
knows you might get a peek at who he
really
the is koreans came pouring over the
38th parallel
our guys need help
and we're up
we knew this day might come
and it doesn't make it any easier
the most important thing is this
we bring everyone
home
mistakes get us
i can't killed
you how many times people have told me
to give up quickly
die even
[Music]
that's why you can't always prove what
you're
told i did
i wouldn't be here
what do you want me to do just be my
wing man
the real battle in all of life
[Music]
is being someone that people can count
on
show off that was pretty good it's good
you